[Musica]
La maestra è sparita Che cosa le è
successo è stata rapita è scomparsa in
questo video dovremmo risolvere un altro
mistero assieme e cioè scoprire Dov'è
finita la maestra e chi è stato rapirla
anche Voi dovrete scoprire assieme a me
chi è il colpevole proprio come nel mio
nuovo libro La città stregata gli
investigatori del mistero che è ora
disponibile per il preordine in questo
nuovo libro dovrete risolvere un mistero
anche voi vi trasformerete degli
investigatori come noi per risolvere il
mistero della città stregata e dentro
c'è anche un alfabeto segreto
preordinatelo subito per ricevere una
sorpresa cliccate nel link in
descrizione per preordinarlo subito e
questo è un video interattivo infatti
alla fine del video avrete quattro
caselline su cui cliccare e nelle
quattro caselline ci saranno i quattro
sospettati che vedete qua dietro Voi
dovrete indovinare chi è il colpevole ci
riuscirete Al primo tentativo state
attenti a tutto il video perché Ci sono
vari indizi nascosti siete pronti
lasciate un bel mi piace perché se
questo video raggiunge i 5000 mi piace
uscirà un nuovo episodio di Risolvi il
mistero ma prima di interrogare i
sospettati vediamo cosa è successo il
giorno che la maestra è stata rapita
Buongiorno maestra
[Musica]
si sieda Dai facciamo una chiacchierata
sul commandata all'estate sta succedendo
qualcosa in passato anche no prof
[Musica]
prof ho fatto io è stata Jenny Sì sì
certo come se fossi stata io e poi da lì
allora
interrogazione scriviamo
[Musica]
c'è il raggio
del cerchio
testa di cavolo latino
Ma lo sapete che dottore direttamente e
sarà tutta un'altra cosa dovete portare
rispetto a dare del lei è professoressa
rà dai cancelliamo questo schifo che
avete fatto qua ma guarda davvero guarda
il triangolo e insoscele quando quando
ci sono due lati uguali e uno di Svezia
però mi sembra appena così poi ve lo
dico
[Musica]
e ora iniziamo subito a interrogare i
sospettati Ciao io sono Ginny e no non
sono assolutamente stata io a rapire la
maestra Santina perché è la mia
preferita Infatti ho 10 in tutte le sue
materie è super bravissima a insegnare
Bella Fra Sono Franky il bullo E so cosa
stai pensando No non sono stato a rapire
la maestra e ti spiego il perché io sono
un assono matematica La adoro la
matematica e posso calcolare per fine
per segno ogni scherzo che io devo fare
i miei compagni quindi non sono stato io
Ciao Bro Ciao io sono serena e non sono
stata io a far sparire la maestra Certo
mi mette molto spesso in punizione
qualche volta mi è capitato di copiare
da Jimmy
però in qualche modo devo fare perché io
la matematica non la capisco e se
tornavo un'altra volta con un brutto
voto a casa mia madre non mi avrebbe più
fatto uscire vi giuro non sono stata io
Io mi chiamo Nico e no non sono stato io
rapidamente a Santina Insomma è mia zia
non sono stato io la maestra è scomparsa
alle 10 e 30 del mattino di lunedì nella
seconda c Ora chiediamo a tutti
sospettati dove si trovavano in quel
momento e vediamo quali sono i loro
alibi interroghiamo ora il nostro
sospettato Ginny Tu dove ti trovavi
lunedì alle 10:30 del mattino Beh io in
quel momento ero in classe con la
maestra era in classe con la maestra Ma
allora hai visto chi la rapita Purtroppo
no perché stavo copiando delle formule
Allora mi sono abbassata poi ho sentito
un rumore e un urlo ho alzato la testa e
boom la maestra non c'era più comunque
sei ancora sospetta perché tu eri
nell'aula nel momento in cui è stata
rapita la maestra ma ora interrompiamo
il nostro prossimo sospettato Ehi tu
sospettato Frank dove ti trovavi quando
la maestra è stata rapita Oh è bravo io
mi trovavo sempre in classe con Jenny li
stavo facendo
uno scherzo è stato divertentissimo
eh eh
[Musica]
non è che magari lo scherzo l'hai fatto
alla maestra e per non subire le
conseguenze le rapita No fra gli scherzi
li faccio solo ai compagni se Non
finirei in punizione come Serena Ah
Serena è finita in punizione Vabbè sei
comunque sospetto ma ora passiamo al
prossimo interrogatorio e tu Serena dove
ti trovavi lunedì mattina alle 10:30
Quando è stata rapita la maestra io ero
qui in quest'aula e Nico e testimone del
mio Alibi Non lo rapita io la maestra e
dimmi una cosa perché la maestra ti ha
messo in punizione Beh ero in punizione
perché non ho fatto i compiti io la
matematica non la capisco
tutte quelle espressioni quei numeri è
troppo difficile e quindi sono stata
messa in punizione io solo bisogno di un
aiuto ma la maestra non mi aiuta questa
maestra devo dire che è molto severa ma
non è comunque un pretesto per rapirla
Beh ci manca solo una persona da
interrogare adesso e tu Nico dove ti
trovavi quando la maestra è stata rapita
Beh a me dispiace molto che la maestra
sia stata rapita ma ero in classe con
Serena ecco
solo che a un certo punto mi è venuta un
certo languorino Allora sono andato alle
macchinette della nostra scuola a
prendere uno snack
[Musica]
a questo Sì è no no no l'ho già preso
l'altro giorno no ma quello lì i soldi
ma quanto costa
è quello no quello sono allergico al
cioccolato sennò mi tocca correre in
bagno
[Musica]
Beh io snack yeah levo il mio Aspetto il
mio Aspetto Voglio il mio fidanzato
[Musica]
il fatto che tu ti sia alzato per un
momento a prendere uno snack alle
macchinette ti rende molto sospetto
perché avresti potuto rapire la maestra
in quel momento no non sono stato io
guarda Aspetta ho ancora l'incarto dello
snack che ho mangiato mi piace molto
mangiare anche durante la lezione ma non
ditelo alla maestra anche se mia zia mi
scriverebbe bene Abbiamo ascoltato gli
alibi di tutti i sospettati non ci resta
ora che fare la nostra cosa Chi è stato
Secondo voi
Cos'è questo Guardate un indizio Questo
è un indizio su chi è il colpevole per
tradurre questo indizio non vi resta che
preordinare il mio nuovo libro La città
stregata perché All'interno c'è un
alfabeto segreto in cui potrete tradurre
i miei messaggi segreti e in questo
messaggio c'è un indizio su chi è il
colpevole Ora tocca a voi decidere chi è
Secondo voi il colpevole cliccate sulla
Casellina di chi secondo voi è il
colpevole e ci vediamo lì cliccate
adesso